could this be the breakthrough Trump
voters have been wanting well House
Majority Leader Kevin McCarthy
introduced a bill earlier this week that
would fund president Trump's wall on the
southern border but it's got to move
fast
if this bill passes the house it would
have to go through the Senate with 60
votes to avoid a filibuster before
January could that possibly happened the
congressman joins us on that and his
trip to the border today all right
congressman McCarthy great to see you
if this were to pass the House and
that's a big if how does the Senate have
any stomach or the votes for this well I
don't think the question is if it will
pass the house the name of this bill is
build the wall enforce the law so it
fully funds the wall 25 billion but it
even does more you know Kate's law which
we passed is a part of this
stop sanctuary cities it keeps children
safe because it removes the ms-13 gang
members and it denounces this movement
like in San Francisco that allows
illegals to vote in our election but I
watched what McConnell just said today
he said we're going to have a vigorous
fight over the wall in December and
watching what this Senate was able to do
with Kavanagh I believe this gives him
the opportunity and the time to get this
done once and for all
yeah I mean I I keep thinking given how
great it was to have the party unified
for a Supreme Court seat if the party
had been as unified in that first year
of the Trump administration on this
issue which was one of his seminal
issues on the campaign trail half of
that wall or maybe 1/4 of that wall
would have been built already so it's
it's frustrating to a lot of us who push
that so hard congressman and I I applaud
you for getting to this now but man
we're frustrated a story today I think I
just saw today in Arizona you probably
saw it that a detention facility there
was so full of all these people still
streaming across the border can't
separate families so they released but
so full they just had to do a mass
release and that that shouldn't be
happening not not with this president he
doesn't want this stuff
no and the battle wouldn't came to
Kavanagh was the rule of law it's one of
the things that makes America the
strongest it breaks down our society and
it our communities will not be safe if
you
can't secure your own borders think of
the amount of fentanyl or the human
trafficking that comes across modern-day
slavery
congressman they do not care they care
more about their their liberal social
construct being foisted on America open
borders open markets you know redefining
the gender fluidity all whatever it's
throw it into the mix whatever it is
it's not about the kids or the rule of
law they don't care about that
it's about redefining America as a
borderless place that's no better than
any other place on earth that's what
it's about
you are correct and that's what this
election is about this is ability to
build the wall and enforce the law or
didn't have a border with no with no
border whatsoever with allowing what
they've done in San Francisco today
allowing illegals to vote in our
elections or when they want to eliminate
ice I would wish every American would
spend one day with a Border Patrol agent
I was down in El Paso this is the first
place that the Border Patrol began they
call it the where the legend all began
if they spend one day with them I don't
think there'd be any question about
building this wall and keeping our
command I mean this is why we have you
there and this is why you know the Fox
News reports on these we had this
horrible horrible example of illegal
immigrant crime a woman raped in New
York well no coverage of this for the
most part in in the mainstream media 0
and again they care about women but we
have a woman raped at the hands of an
illegal alien and just like it never
even happened congressman I've got to
get you to react to this ever-increasing
rabid mob like atmosphere among a very
strong virulent strain of the Democrat
Party Maxine Waters reacted to the mob
question let's watch there are people
who hear that and they think what you're
calling for is physical intimidation
things that fray at the social fabric
that is absolutely untrue if they would
like to take and redefine somehow
protest and call it something else
they'll try and do that yes we're
shouting out we have signs we're saying
what we think will get to the public and
we are not saying we're going to kill
anybody we're gonna hit anybody
oh we're gonna cause any
in a harm that's a lie in the way that
they're trying to redefine protests
congressman route of time but she said
getting their faces what does that all
mean that means if they were to win the
majority she'd be the chair of Financial
Services one who asked people to
actually cause problems to other
individuals it's the opposite of what we
expect from our elected officials that's
why this November is so important to
make a fundamental difference and not
let the Democrats take everything
everyone's got to get out to vote thank
you so much congressman